[Music]
it's time to grow myself
large and wide if growing large and
white is the goal of this episode we can
be done now as spongebob literally just
grew himself both large and wide
impaling your stuffed toys repetitively
apparently sandy's underwater suit isn't
compromised after she rolls up her
sleeves does that mean her helmet is a
self-containing air unit in which case
why would she wear anything other than a
helmet
be free sandy be free i can see me
now well coincidentally i wasn't
interested in getting any sleep over the
next couple of weeks so thanks for that
nightmare fuel
also spongebob can change the shape to
just about anything he can imagine so
looking like this would take little to
no effort are you too much of a whip to
work out convenient commercial position
is convenient and commercial positiony
sorta now wow now that's a good idea
taking advice from sharks i want to be
just like him
yeah i've got to get to a phone the
phone lying on the floor that you just
used to call sandy doesn't count
wearing bikini bottoms at bikini bottom
dude
you're ripped he's also controlling
balloon extensions with the power of his
mind but yeah let's focus on the arm
muscles
so he's too weak to lift a straw but
strong enough to sport his own body
weight earlier
some consistency would be appreciated
the underside of a bikini bottom is
absolutely a sin
what's your secret does sandy believe
that spongebob's muscles are the real
deal because she
literally just trained with him and
knows a lot about conditioning so she
should know that he's either full of
sponge or he has abnormal growths and
should go to a hospital immediately
here's your drink who would set a drink
there and if they would how would they
still have a job as a server
sandy doesn't put any spacing between
spongebob and squarepants which means
sandy is insane
it's okay spongebob i already signed
your name in i mean poor spongebob what
will he ever do to get out of this
it's not like you could just go home and
not show up for the competition except
he absolutely can and he absolutely
should but an animated sitcom has to
animated sitcom i guess
blowing yourself in public let's see an
instant replay
that is not an instant replay that is
simply a second turn sandy tosses the
anchor upwards but then kicks it out
over
the field i'm fairly sure she would be
disqualified considering this is the
anchor toss
not the anchor kick jerking yourself
in public considering spongebob is a
well sponge
i'm surprised that any amount of air
would stay contained inside him at all
salmon spreading
you all swallowed up you look like
you're ready to explode
i got it i got it i got it
[Music]
good night gary good night
[Music]
what happened to my body